Ti hanno sempre detto che il debito
pubblico è il problema, che i governi
spendono troppo, che i numeri sono fuori
controllo, che qualcuno prima o poi
dovrà pagare il conto. E se ti dicessi
che il debito non è il vero problema,
che il vero problema è un altro e che
nessuno te lo spiega perché la verità è
molto più scomoda, bene, in questo video
ti porto dentro una storia che riguarda
te, i tuoi risparmi, il tuo futuro. Una
storia che parte da un economista
inglese morto nel 1946,
passa per Roma a Termini, arriva a
Washington e finisce dentro il tuo conto
in banca. Perché il sistema in cui
viviamo, il sistema che tiene in piedi i
nostri stipendi, le nostre pensioni, il
valore della nostra casa, quel sistema è
costruito su un'idea geniale, ma che è
stata tradita e quel tradimento ha delle
conseguenze che stanno arrivando oggi.
Perché quando avrai finito di guardare
questo video vedrai i telegiornali e
leggerei gli articoli in modo
completamente diverso, vedrai i titoli
sul debito in modo diverso e soprattutto
vedrai i tuoi risparmi in modo diverso.
Ma partiamo dall'inizio. Salve a tutti,
Marco Casario. Qui sono l'autore del
libro I quattro pilastri
dell'indipendenza finanziaria e c'è un
numero che tutti citano ma che nessuno
capisce davvero, il debito pubblico. In
Italia siamo a circa il 150% del PIL, in
Giappone oltre il 250%.
Gli Stati Uniti hanno superato i 36.000
miliardi di dollari di debito. Bene,
messi insieme tutti i paesi del mondo
devono circa 100.000 miliardi di
dollari. 100.000 miliardi. E allora la
domanda che fanno tutti è ma se tutti i
paesi sono indebitati, ma a chi devono
ridare tutti questi soldi? È una domanda
che sembra banale, ma la risposta è
tutto tranne che banale. Il debito
pubblico di un paese non è come il
debito che noi abbiamo con la nostra
banca. Noi abbiamo preso il mutuo,
dobbiamo restituire i soldi a qualcuno
che li aveva prima di noi. Ma un governo
non funziona così, perché quando un
governo emette debito sta facendo
qualcosa di molto più sofisticato, sta
creando moneta. Fermati un attimo su
questo concetto perché è la chiave di
tutto e voglio che tu la capisca bene.
Ogni volta che un governo emette un
titolo di stato, un BTP italiano, un
Treasury americano, un Bund tedesco, sta
mettendo in circolazione denaro nel
sistema. Quel debito diventa un asset,
un attivo per chi lo compra. Quindi il
deficit dello Stato diventa il surplus
del settore privato. L'inchiostro rosso
del governo è l'inchiostro verde delle
famiglie e delle imprese. Se ogni volta
che ti è stata fatta questa domanda sei
davvero preoccupato per il debito
pubblico e tu hai risposto di sì, beh,
considera questo grafico. Da una parte
c'è il deficit del governo, dall'altra
c'è il surplus del settore privato. due
linee sono praticamente speculari,
perfettamente speculari, perché quando
il governo è in deficit, il settore
privato è in surplus. Quindi eliminare
il deficit del governo significa
eliminare il risparmio di tutti gli
altri. E allora chi possiede questo
debito? probabilmente tu, senza nemmeno
saperlo, perché oltre l'80% del debito
mondiale è in mani private, fondi
pensione, assicurazioni sulla vita,
fondi di investimento. Il debito
pubblico italiano, per esempio, che
supera i 3.000 miliardi di euro, è
detenuto principalmente da investitori
esteri, circa il 30% a seconda delle
stime recenti, seguiti poi da Banca
d'Italia, dalle banche italiane e da
investitori privati. Famiglie e imprese
italiane detengono una quota crescente
che è arrivata a circa il 14,4%
nel 2025. Quindi il debito pubblico non
è solo moneta in circolazione, è la
spina dorsale del sistema finanziario
privato, è il fondamento della ricchezza
privata. Ma ecco dove la storia diventa
interessante, perché questa ricchezza
non è distribuita in modo uniforme, no?
Gli interessi pagati sul debito pubblico
mondiale ammontano a circa 3.000
miliardi di dollari l'anno. 3.000
miliardi. E siccome la proprietà del
debito è concentrata nelle mani dell'1%
più ricco del pianeta, parliamo di circa
80 milioni di persone, questo significa
che ogni anno in media ognuno di loro
riceve circa $40.000
solo di interessi sul debito pubblico e
il 99% restante ha un reddito medio
generato da lavoro di circa $13.500 $00
l'anno. Capisci cosa significa? I più
ricchi guadagnano quasi tre volte di più
solo di interessi. È reddito non
guadagnato. Soldi che arrivano solo
perché possiedi qualcosa rispetto a
quanto il resto del mondo guadagna
lavorando. Ed ogni volta che un governo
emette nuovo debito, questa dinamica si
rafforza, cioè i ricchi diventano ancora
più ricchi, non perché lavorano di più,
ma perché il sistema è costruito per
premiarli. E lo sai qual è la cosa più
assurda? che il reddito da capitale, gli
interessi, i dividendi, le plusvalenze è
tassato meno del reddito da lavoro in
quasi tutti i paesi del mondo. Cioè tu
che ti alzi la mattina e vai a lavorare
paghi più tasse di chi incassa cedole
stando seduto sul divano. Questo non è
un bug del sistema, questo è il sistema.
Però aspetta, perché allora tutti dicono
che il debito è un problema. E qui entra
in scena l'uomo che ha cambiato tutto,
John Maynard Kanes. Kanes non era un
politico, non era un rivoluzionario,
almeno non nel senso classico, era
qualcosa di più raro. Era un uomo che ha
insegnato a intere nazioni come spendere
per uscire dalla disperazione. Sì,
perché per secoli il debito era un
peccato, i deficit erano fallimenti
morali, il bilancio in pareggio era il
segno di un governo onesto e Kanes ha
ribaltato tutto. Ha detto: "Spendere nei
momenti difficili non è irresponsabile,
è doveroso. Ha trasformato il debito in
dovere e il risparmio in egoismo." E
facendo questo ha riscritto le regole
del capitalismo e il suo ragionamento,
guardate, era semplice ma devastante
allo stesso tempo. Immagina un attimo il
mondo nel 1930. Le banche crollano, le
fabbriche sono silenziose, milioni di
persone sono senza lavoro. La teoria
economica classica diceva: "Il mercato
tanto prima o poi si aggiusterà da solo.
La domanda e l'offerta troveranno un
nuovo equilibrio, basta aspettare." E il
problema è che l'attesa non sfama le
famiglie, la domanda non tornava, le
fabbriche non riaprivano e le persone
terrorizzate smettevano di spendere.
l'economia non si stava correggendo, si
stava congelando. Bene, Kanes guardò
tutto questo e capì qualcosa di
radicale. I mercati non sono perfetti,
non si guariscono sempre da soli, a
volte si bloccano in un circolo vizioso
di paura. Quando la gente smette di
spendere, le aziende smettono di
assumere. Quando le aziende smettono di
assumere, i redditi calano. Quando i
redditi calano, la spesa crolla ancora
di più. È una spirale, una specie di
buco nero economico. Bene, allora Kanes
propose qualcosa di eretico. Se la
domanda privata crolla, la domanda
pubblica deve sostituirla. Il governo
deve intervenire. Il governo deve
prendere in prestito denaro, deve
assumere lavoratori, deve costruire
infrastrutture, deve rimettere soldi in
circolazione. Quei soldi creeranno posti
di lavoro, i posti di lavoro creeranno
reddito, il reddito crea spesa, la spesa
riavvia la macchina. Ma e questo è il
punto che tutti dimenticano, Kanes non
stava dicendo che il debito è sempre
buono, stava dicendo che il tempismo è
tutto. I governi dovrebbero agire in
modo controciclico, cioè dovrebbero
spendere durante le crisi e dovrebbero
risparmiare durante i boom economici,
stimolo e disciplina, non uno o l'altro,
ma entrambi in alternanza. Usiamo una
metafora semplice dicendo che l'economia
è come un'automobile. In tempi normali è
il settore privato che la guida, ma
quando l'auto si ferma il governo deve
girare la chiave, deve pompare
carburante nel motore fino a quando non
riparte. Una volta che il motore gira,
allora il governo fa un passo indietro.
E questa idea ha funzionato. Ha
funzionato in America durante il New
Deal di Roosevelt con i progetti
pubblici massicci come la Tennessee
Valley Authority, come la diga di U che
diedero lavoro a milioni di persone. Il
governo divenne il più grande datore di
lavoro del paese pagando stipendi
direttamente nel sistema circolatorio
dell'economia e lentamente la macchina
si riavviò. La domanda tornò, la fiducia
crebbe, ma la prova definitiva di questo
sistema arrivò con qualcosa di molto più
grande e lasciatemi dire molto più buio,
la guerra. Quando scoppiò la Seconda
Guerra Mondiale, i governi fecero
esattamente quello che Kanes aveva
proposto, cioè spesero senza esitazione.
Le fabbriche riaprirono non per produrre
beni di consumo, ma per produrre carri
armati, navi, aerei, munizioni. I
governi presero in prestito cifre enormi
e per la prima volta nella storia la
disoccupazione svanì nel mezzo di una
crisi globale. L'ironia era brutale,
cioè la guerra totale divenne
l'esperimento definitivo dell'economia
kenesiana. La produzione esplose, i
redditi salirono, le economie tornarono
a ruggire, non era prosperità, era la
prova che la spesa pubblica su larga
scala poteva porre fine ad una
depressione. Ha funzionato nel
dopoguerra, durante quei 30 anni
gloriosi di crescita, dal 1945 al 1973,
recessioni più brevi, riprese più
rapide. Il ciclo economico che una volta
era trattato come il tempo atmosferico,
cioè qualcosa su cui non si aveva
proprio controllo, diventò qualcosa che
i governi credevano di poter gestire.
Per la prima volta nella storia il
capitalismo era al guinzaglio e Kanes
aveva messo quel guinzaglio nelle mani
dello Stato. Però poi è successa una
cosa. I politici hanno imparato ad usare
solo metà della formula del sistema
kinesiano. Hanno imparato la parte dello
spendere. hanno dimenticato la parte del
risparmiare e qui c'è il tradimento.
Kanes aveva progettato un sistema con
due pedali, un acceleratore ed un freno
e i governi hanno staccato il freno,
hanno tenuto l'acceleratore premuto
sempre in tempi buoni e in tempi cattivi
e il sistema che doveva essere uno
stabilizzatore è diventato una
dipendenza e i politici hanno scoperto
che agli elettori piace lo stimolo, ma
non piace la disciplina. Eppure la
regola d'oro di Kanes, surplus nei tempi
buoni, deficit nei tempi cattivi, è
stata convenientemente dimenticata. E
così decennio dopo decennio il debito è
salito non perché ce ne fosse bisogno,
ma perché era comodo. E quando nel 2008
i mercati globali sono crollati sotto il
peso della propria avidità, il vecchio
riflesso è tornato. Salvataggi bancari,
pacchetti di stimolo, quantityasing,
tutti versione del playbook originale di
Kanes, ma su una scala che lui non
avrebbe mai immaginato. migliaia di
miliardi stampati, tassi di interesse
tagliati a zero e di nuovo ha funzionato
alla grande, almeno all'inizio. Il
sistema non è crollato, la fiducia è
tornata, i mercati sono saliti, ma la
ripresa ha rivelato un nuovo squilibrio,
uno che Kanes non aveva previsto. La sua
teoria assumeva che la spesa pubblica
avrebbe raggiunto i lavoratori, le
famiglie, le industrie, l'economia
reale. Ma nel XX secolo il denaro scorre
diversamente. Lo stimolo ha inondato i
mercati finanziari, non i pavimenti
delle fabbriche. Ha gonfiato il prezzo
degli asset, degli immobili, non i
salari. Le azioni sono salite,
l'immobiliare è esploso, la
disuguaglianza è esplosa. Il governo
aveva imparato a riavviare il motore, ma
stava mettendo il turbo dalla parte
sbagliata del sistema. E poi è arrivata
la pandemia, il Covid e Kanes è stato
resuscitato nella sua forma più pura
assegni direttamente nei conti correnti.
Banche centrali che stampano migliaia di
miliardi in una notte. Per un momento
sembrava magia, la disoccupazione
crollò, i mercati toccarono il record e
poi il conto è arrivato, l'inflazione è
tornata a ruggire e ancora una volta la
cura che aveva salvato il sistema lo
aveva anche indebolito. Oggi il rapporto
debito su PIL medio dei paesi sviluppati
è tornato ai livelli del 1945. Sai cosa
c'era nel 1945? la seconda guerra
mondiale. Allora c'era una ragione per
indebitarsi fino al collo. Oggi la
ragione è che nessun politico vuole dire
ai suoi elettori basta e questo ci porta
dritti come una catapulta in Italia,
perché l'Italia è il caso di studio
perfetto di tutto quello che abbiamo
detto finora. La dimostrazione vivente
che il debito in sé non è il problema.
Il problema è un altro. A Roma Termini e
anche a Milano Centrale c'era un
orologio, non segnava l'ora, segnava il
debito pubblico italiano in tempo reale.
Era stato installato nel febbraio del
2018 dall'Istituto Bruno Leoni per
mostrare in tempo reale la crescita del
debito pubblico italiano. Bene, allora
segnalava una quota di più di €40.000 a
testa. Oggi quella quota procapite
supera i €52.000
per abitante, inclusi bambini e anziani
e i numeri salgono, salgono, salgono. Il
messaggio è chiaro. L'Italia ha un
problema di debito, lo ripetono i
politici del Nord Europa, gli
editorialisti olandesi, i commentatori
tedeschi. L'Italia spende troppo,
l'Italia è irresponsabile, l'Italia è il
malato d'Europa. Bene, ma se ti dicessi
che quell'orologio e quel numero è
fuorviante, il Dutch Institute for
Public Economics, che è un istituto
olandese non italiano, quindi non
sospettabile di partigianeria, ha
pubblicato un rapporto che dice una cosa
molto semplice: il debito italiano, in
termini assoluti, è cresciuto più o meno
come quello tedesco e belga. Ascolta
bene, il debito italiano è cresciuto
quanto quello tedesco. Ma allora perché
il rapporto debito su PIL è così alto in
Italia? Non perché il numeratore è
esploso il debito, ma perché il
denominatore è crollato il PIL. L'Italia
non ha un problema di debito, l'Italia
ha un problema di crescita. Dal 2008 ad
oggi la Germania è cresciuta del 22%, la
Francia del 17%, l'Italia l'Italia è
ancora sotto del 4% rispetto al livello
precrisi.
Non è una recessione, è una generazione
perduta. E sai qual è l'ironia più
crudele? Una delle ragioni per cui
l'Italia non cresce è proprio perché ha
fatto quello che il Nord Europa le
chiedeva. Ha tagliato la spesa. Dopo la
crisi dell'euro del 2011 sotto pressione
dei paesi del nord. L'Italia ha fatto
austerità, ha tagliato gli investimenti
nei servizi pubblici, nelle scuole,
nella sanità, ha alzato l'età
pensionabile a 67 anni, più alta che per
esempio nei paesi bassi dove vivo, e lo
ha fatto senza aumentare le tasse. La
BCE stessa nel 2015 ha giudicato gli
sforzi di austerità italiana
significativamente superiore a quelli
tedeschi. Ed il risultato? Beh, i
ricercatori stimano che il PIL italiano
sia calato di un ulteriore 5% proprio a
causa dell'austerità. Hai sentito bene?
Tagliando la spesa, l'Italia ha
peggiorato il suo rapporto debito su
PIL. Com'è possibile? Perché il governo
italiano rappresenta circa il 50%
dell'economia. È enorme. E quando un
soggetto così grande taglia la spesa,
l'effetto si moltiplica nell'economia.
licenze insegnanti, eh, pagano meno
tasse e hanno bisogno di sussidi. Quegli
ex insegnanti spendono meno in
alimentari e quindi il contadino
guadagna meno, il negoziante guadagna
meno, tutti pagano meno tasse, tutti
hanno bisogno di più sostegno sociale.
Il taglio iniziale si moltiplica e alla
fine il PIL cala più di quanto risparmi.
Il rapporto debito su PIL peggiora. È
come se un medico ti dicesse "C'hai la
febbre?" Bene, la cura è smettere di
mangiare e tu smetti di mangiare e la
febbre sale ancora di più perché il tuo
corpo non ha più l'energia per
combattere l'infezione, ma c'è di più
perché il problema dell'Italia non è
stata solo l'austerità, la produttività
italiana ha cominciato a rallentare
proprio quando l'Italia è entrata
nell'euro. Con l'euro l'Italia ha perso
la possibilità di svalutare la propria
valuta per mantenere la competitività.
prima dell'euro, quando le imprese
italiane erano in difficoltà, la lira si
svalutava attraverso la banca centrale e
le esportazioni potevano ripartire. Con
l'euro quella valvola di sfogo è sparita
e l'unica opzione è rimasta è stata
l'austerità, un'economia dominata da
piccole imprese familiari che non sono
riuscite a tenere il passo con la
digitalizzazione.
Un'economia sommersa, quella del nero
che non paga le tasse, che vale il 25%
del PIL. centinaia di miliardi di euro
che sfuggono al fisco, che limitano gli
investimenti in infrastrutture e servizi
pubblici, che contribuiscono alla
stagnazione e un sistema pensionistico
che assorbe il 16% del PIL che è secondo
solo alla Grecia tra i paesi dell'Oxe. E
lo schema pensionistico permette di
andare in pensione a 62 anni con solo 38
anni di contributi. Accelera il
collasso. una popolazione con un'età
mediana di 47 anni che è una delle più
vecchie al mondo e un tasso di natalità
di 1,24 nascite per donna, lontanissimo
dal 2,1 necessario per la stabilità.
Capite qual è il problema? Nel 2023
abbiamo avuto 380.000 nascite in meno,
minimo storico, 50.000 giovani che se ne
vanno ogni anno dall'Italia, non per
avventura, per disperazione, portandosi
via le competenze, l'energia, il
cervello, il futuro. Entro il 2050
l'Italia potrebbe avere più di 70
anziani, ogni persone in età lavorativa.
E chi pagherà le pensioni? Chi pagherà
il debito? Chi terrà in piedi il
sistema? Mentre la Francia lancia nuove
porte aerei, la Germania annuncia 100
miliardi di modernizzazione militare. La
Marina italiana opera ancora con navi
degli anni 80. Il budget difesa è fermo
all'1,5% del PIL da decenni, sotto il 2%
richiesto dalla NATO. Il Mediterraneo,
una volta il mare nostrum è sempre più
dominato dai droni turchi, dalle navi
russe, dalle flotte mercantili cinesi e
quindi quando senti dire "L'Italia ha
troppo debito". La domanda giusta da
fare non è "Ma come facciamo a ridurre
il debito?" No, la domanda giusta è come
facciamo a far crescere questae economia
italiana? Perché il debito diventa un
problema solo quando l'economia non
cresce abbastanza per sostenerlo. E qui
c'è una lezione che vale per tutti, non
solo per noi italiani. Ci sono
economisti che dicono "Ma l'importante
non è il debito assoluto, ma il costo
degli interessi rispetto al PIL". Lry
Summers, l'ex segretario al tesoro
americano e Olivier Blanchard, ex capoe
economista del Fondo Monetario
Internazionale, hanno fatto un
ragionamento molto semplice. Se prendi
in prestito dei soldi e la crescita
economica che generi è superiore agli
interessi che paghi, puoi continuare a
prendere in prestito. Il debito rispetto
al PIL non esploderà, convergerà e per
anni questa logica ha funzionato. I
tassi di interesse sono rimasti
bassissimi, il costo del debito rispetto
al PIL non è salito, anche se il debito
stesso è esploso. Per esempio,
l'economia americana ha continuato a
crescere e tutti si sono convinti che
questa fosse la nuova normalità. Però
c'è un problema, un problema enorme.
Questa logica funziona solo finché i
tassi restano bassi e i tassi oggi non
sono più bassi. Oggi gli Stati Uniti
spendono 880 miliardi di dollari l'anno
solo di interessi sul debito, quattro
volte il livello di 10 anni fa. Più del
budget militare, quasi quanto la spesa
sanitaria. Gli interessi si stanno
avvicinando al 25% di tutte le entrate
federali. È la classica trappola del
debito. Prendi in prestito per pagare
gli interessi sul debito precedente.
Questa cosa succede anche in Italia, eh?
È come prendere una nuova carta di
credito per pagare quella vecchia. E il
Wall Street Journal ha fatto un
esercizio molto interessante. Ha chiesto
a che punto il debito americano diventa
davvero insostenibile. La risposta degli
economisti è stata: al 175% del debito
su PIL le cose diventano molto molto
difficili. Al 200% è game over, non puoi
alzare le tasse abbastanza per pagare
gli interessi. Lo sapete quali sono le
proiezioni peggiori per gli Stati Uniti?
160% da qui a 10 anni. Ma ecco la cosa
che dovrebbe farti drizzare le orecchie.
Non serve arrivare a quelle soglie
perché il sistema salti. Basta che gli
investitori perdano fiducia e quel
momento può arrivare domani. Dopo
l'annuncio dei dazzi di Trump è successa
una cosa che ha scioccato gli economisti
e lasciami dire anche me. Non il crollo
delle borse, quello era prevedibile, è
crollato in dollari, in tempi di
turbolenza il dollaro di solito sale,
gli investitori corrono verso il dollaro
come porto sicuro. Questa volta è
successo il contrario. Il denaro è
fuggito dagli Stati Uniti, non verso gli
Stati Uniti, ma dagli Stati Uniti. Per
la prima volta nella memoria recente il
mondo ha guardato l'America e ha detto
"Non mi fido" e questo è il segnale più
pericoloso di tutti, perché tutto il
sistema finanziario globale è costruito
sulla fiducia nel dollaro e nei treasury
americani, nei titoli di stato
americani. Quando quella fiducia
vacilla, tutto vacilla. E allora cosa
succederà ai nostri risparmi? Cosa
succederà ai nostri BTP? Cosa succederà
ai nostri fondi pensione? Succede che
viviamo in un momento di transizione, un
momento in cui le regole del gioco
stanno cambiando. I governi
continueranno ad emettere debito, non
possono farne a meno. Ma il modo in cui
quel debito viene assorbito, chi lo
compra, a che prezzo, tutto questo sta
cambiando. Quelli che vengono chiamati
bond vigilantes, no? quei grandi
investitori obbligazionari che in teoria
dovrebbero punire i governi che spendono
troppo alzando i tassi esistono ancora.
Ed Yardani, è stato lui ad inventare
questo termine nel 1983, crede che
possono ancora disciplinare i governi,
ma c'è uno storico finanziario Russell
Napier che la pensa diversamente e dice
che i vigilantes verranno assassinati
non letteralmente, ma i governi
troveranno il modo di forzare le persone
a comprare titoli di stato a tassi che
qualsiasi investitore considererebbe
inaccettabili. quello che è successo
dopo la seconda guerra mondiale, eh non
hanno lasciato che il mercato decidesse
il prezzo del credito governativo, lo
hanno imposto, si chiama repressione
finanziaria e Nepier dice che sta per
tornare. E quindi cosa significa per
noi? Significa che i nostri risparmi,
quelli nei fondi pensione, quelli nei
BTP, quelli nei conti deposito, eh
potrebbero renderti meno dell'inflazione
per i prossimi anni, non perché li
perdi, ma perché il loro rendimento
reale viene mangiato piano piano
dall'inflazione, dalla tassa invisibile.
Non te la addebitano, non te la
comunicano, ma i tuoi soldi perdono
valore anno dopo anno. Blanchard, che è
francese e conosce molto bene l'Europa,
lo ha detto chiaramente. Francia servono
150 miliardi di euro di aggiustamento
per stabilizzare il rapporto debito su
PIL. È assolutamente impossibile
nell'attuale contesto politico. Serve
probabilmente una crisi per forzare i
cambiamenti e nel frattempo la Germania,
che per decenni è stata la paladina
dell'austerità ha deciso di indebitarsi
massicciamente per difesa e
infrastrutture. La comunità degli
investitori glielo chiedeva da 15 anni,
ma la Germania ha pagato il prezzo della
sua prudenza. Crescita lenta,
consumatori cauti, incapace di competere
con la Cina sui veicoli elettrici. Tutto
è connesso. Il debito dell'Italia, la
prudenza della Germania, il deficit
americano, la paura dei mercati, tuoi
risparmi, tutto. E allora cosa fare?
Beh, la prima cosa è capire che il
debito pubblico non è quello che ti
hanno raccontato. Prendere
consapevolezza. Queste cose le dobbiamo
sapere capire per non farci prendere in
giro. Il debito non è un peso che grava
sulle future generazioni. Il debito è
moneta, è il fondamento del sistema
finanziario, è quello che permette ai
fondi pensione di esistere, ma è anche
uno strumento che, se usato male,
concentra la ricchezza in poche mani e
erode il potere d'acquisto di tutti gli
altri. La seconda cosa da capire è che
l'Italia non ha un problema di debito,
smettiamo di dirlo, ha un problema di
crescita e quel problema non si risolve
tagliando, si risolve investendo in
istruzione, infrastrutture digitali, in
sanità, in ferrovia, in trasporti. Sì,
lo so che questo può temporaneamente
aumentare il rapporto debito su PIL, ma
nel lungo periodo è l'unico modo per
ridurlo. La terza cosa da capire è dove
siamo ora nel ciclo. Siamo in un momento
in cui le regole stanno cambiando, in
cui il mondo sta cambiando, in cui la
fiducia nel sistema si sta erodendo, in
cui i governi prima o poi dovranno
scegliere o lasciano che i mercati li
disciplinino o impongono le loro
condizioni ai mercati. E in entrambi i
casi chi paga il prezzo sono i
risparmiatori che non capiscono cosa sta
succedendo. Perché la verità è questa,
l'inflazione è una tassa nascosta e i
governi la useranno perché serve anche a
loro, perché hanno bisogno di erodere il
debito attraverso l'inflazione
lentamente, anno dopo anno. Potrebbe
essere l'opzione alla fine meno
peggiore. Ma perché funzioni
l'inflazione deve essere inattesa,
perché se i mercati la prevedono allora
i rendimenti obbligazionari salgono, il
governo non migliora la sua situazione.
Quindi il gioco dei governi è mantenerla
appena sotto la soglia del dolore,
abbastanza alta da erodere il debito,
abbastanza bassa da non scatenare una
rivolta e noi siamo nel mezzo con i
nostri BTP che rendono il 2, il 3, il 4%
quando l'inflazione reale è sopra al 4%.
Con il tuo conto deposito che ti dà un
tasso che suona bene ma che al netto
dell'inflazione è negativo. Vedi, non
stai perdendo soldi in apparenza. Stai
perdendo potere d'acquisto ogni mese,
ogni giorno, ogni anno e questo è
esattamente il loro piano. Non è un
complotto, non è una cospirazione, è
come funziona il sistema economico
quando il debito è troppo grande per
essere ripagato e troppo importante per
essere eliminato. Kanes aveva ragione su
una cosa fondamentale. L'economia non è
solo numeri. L'economia è psicologia, è
fiducia, è quello che la gente crede nel
futuro. Quando le persone perdono
fiducia smettono di spendere. E quando
smettono di spendere l'economia muore.
Caput. Il sistema che Kanes ha costruito
per mantenere viva quella fiducia è
stato tradito non da un nemico esterno,
è stato tradito dai suoi stessi
beneficiari, dai politici che hanno
usato solo metà della formula, dai
banchieri che hanno inondato i mercati
finanziari invece dell'economia reale,
da un sistema che ha premiato chi già
aveva a spese di chi lavorava e
produceva davvero. E adesso siamo qui
con un debito globale di 100.000
miliardi, con i tassi che salgono, con
la fiducia che vacilla, con un'Italia
che non cresce da 20 anni e con te che
ti chiedi "Ma i miei soldi sono al
sicuro?" E la risposta onesta è:
"Dipende da cosa ci stai facendo adesso,
dipende da quanto capisci questo gioco e
queste dinamiche, dipende da quanto sei
disposto a guardare oltre i titoli del
giornale e capire come funziona davvero
il sistema." Perché il debito non è il
nemico, come ci vogliono far credere.
L'ignoranza sul debito, quella sì,
quello è il nemico. Spero che questo
video ti abbia portato punti di
riflessione. Se ti è stato utile,
lasciami un commento qui sotto.
Iscriviti al canale. È veramente l'unica
cosa che che ti chiedo per aiutarmi a
continuare a portare questa conoscenza
sul canale. Condividi questo video con
più persone possibili perché queste cose
le devono sapere tutti, è l'unico modo
per salvarci. Grazie mille per
l'attenzione, buoni investimenti a
tutti. Co?